so batgirl you hear about this
no
the movie
no it didn't come out so i don't know
anything about it
well it
well it's not yeah it's not going to
come out now
yeah i got it
the budget was like 90 million bucks
right
well first of all some uh so i guess
some background discovery and warner
brothers merged zazlav who is the
uh ceo who was the ceo of discovery is
now the ceo of
the merged company
and i guess like what he was known for
at discovery is kind of
i think he's like a real by the numbers
ceo yeah like doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about creative or creatives it seems
and so he's kind of just like making
huge moves
and just axing things just to like save
money or optimize for profits
and now that he's ceo of like both
companies he's kind of taking the same
approach
but you know warner brothers has the dc
world hbo yeah and so he's kind of just
leaving this path of scorched earth in
his wake as he just like
optimizes for profits one of the many
things that he's now shut down is
batgirl which is a movie that they spent
90 million bucks on i think yeah and it
was done
it's done it's like in the final
parts of post post-production and he
basically was like no one's ever gonna
see this because we're taking a tax
write off on it which means
it can't touch any form of monetization
so they couldn't even put it on
streaming services if they wanted if
they wanted to because then they
wouldn't get the tax write off like
imagine auditioning for a movie like
this getting the [ __ ] role shooting
it and then sitting back and being like
this role is gonna change my life and
then you know months before it comes out
it's axed i mean it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
that dude
you know how old is zazz live the
discovery ceo he was weird i'm friends
with his son
what yeah what time calls with him oh
interesting he was also a software
engineer
so he was a computer science so i should
have made fun of his dad right now
oh you can if you want
look at this guy
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] dude
you cannot tell me he doesn't look like
a marvel super villain
[Music]
when he saw batgirl coming out with a
movie he was like nah
not on my watch
oh and you know what's more is that the
directors there's two directors and they
were both in morocco for one of their's
wedding oh sick and that's when they got
the news sick at the guy's wedding here
it is adil
l arby and bilal falah found out batgirl
was canceled whilst they were in morocco
for adil's wedding apparently this has
like never happened before just in terms
of
yeah big studios
and canning projects yeah did he can any
other projects yeah uh there's a
scooby-doo movie they're scoring it
right now so it's like literally in the
final stage wow production so this was
like last week that this was happening
and now
as of like friday
he they announced in their earnings call
that they were also he's rebranding hbo
max
so discovery plus and hbo max are
merging
like the streaming apps
and i don't think it's going to be
called hbo max anymore
i just want to imagine that
he just walked in there and was like a
girl movie
um isn't it batman yeah isn't it batman
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this batgirl nonsense
is this a typo that someone has to
explain to him no there's a there's
different
characters in the universe there's
there's also batgirl
nah
nah it's not that's not the dc i know
oh yeah he's also the guy that acts
cnn plus when that came out like three
days after and laid off like 200 people
or whatever it was i mean that i'm going
to say is a good idea cnn yeah laying up
200 people i'm not saying it's right
yeah i know but i'm saying i mean all of
these could end up being good moves
like
from a business standpoint yeah it is
really cutthroat
right yeah like when someone comes in
and it's like i only care about
earnings that's it yeah especially in a
creative industry like there's a lot of
people where
that right now think like there's a lot
more that matters than just numbers it's
like the fans
just like everything creative
the production you know
and he's just he's like well what's the
show's succession
it
it didn't do didn't do too good compared
to its last season yeah
i think we're done here yeah everyone's
like oh yeah
we're gonna make this a reality show
actually we're to make it real
yeah i'm just struggling to know like i
want to know more about this guy let's
go back to kingpin
he looks like
respectfully like a mars attacks alien
in skin dude
respectfully okay anyone can get these
jokes he's he's not you know he's not
immune oh also he was the highest paid
ceo last year i think or like the last
couple years oh okay
that's [ __ ] it's he's just like nah i
thought the background movie was a great
idea but
i wanted to buy a yeah so
like well you already spent the 90
million on it so
yeah you're not getting that back yeah
but you do a tax write-off take a
company takes a l as they say take l
yeah daddy gets his yacht zazlov's
executive compensation package includes
an annual salary of 3 million bucks with
an annual 22 million dollar bonus there
you go and he also received stock
options valued at 190 million dollars
there you go
minted yeah rolling in it yeah he's not
a fan of scripted content the man turned
shows like deadliest catch naked and
afraid dirty jobs man versus wild and
near countless others into low-cost hits
yeah so that's what he does he's a
master
at creating these shows
that just
are revenue machines yeah deadliest
catch yeah it's a cheap show to make
yeah you're not just like
don't people die on that show deadliest
catch yeah deadliest catch is the people
risking their lives so
people in l.a can have sushi right yeah
yeah pretty much isn't that so that
[ __ ] just that juxtaposition of just
some dude in l.a being like
i don't know man kind of mid no boo's
way better talk to a dude like a storm
30 foot swell
yeah then his boy just gets like
like caught in a chain and thrown in the
[ __ ] ocean
dude sugarfish is like kind of mid these
days it's just not that good
[Laughter]
yeah one more california roll please
thanks so anyways what were you saying
your influencer no yeah um
just started my surf channel honestly it
kind of pisses me off like the spicy
tuna here used to be way more cracking
dudes just vomiting and puking from
like 90 days of seasickness that's what
makes your sushi yeah i guess that's
what makes her sushi no one's ever seen
this side
of
you know the food industry no one has
had a a window into the trauma that
these guys face
he's like
so we don't have to pay location cost
unscripted is cheap and therefore he
likes it more
it's like a kid's soccer game everyone
saw something that worked and started
chasing the ball it's way too expensive
he once said of scripted entertainment
holy [ __ ] people look people have
accused zazlab of hating movies
that's so sick yeah what's your favorite
movie i don't really [ __ ] with movies
yes not into movies personally sounds
like someone i know
yeah honestly
i mean i like movies i just don't watch
them
[Laughter]
this i think
not not to make some
overarching prediction about society or
whatever but
i feel that this just underscores
where media is now
no one gives a [ __ ]
you